hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester here we have
again between Magnus Carlsen and Maxime
vasila graph
for the to classical games between the
two of them have been drawn then the two
rapid games between the two of them have
been drawn I thought about trying them
but the games between ding and 11 were
just much more much more exciting even
though both both of the games were
really awesome
however they ended in a draw then the
first game of the blitz section ended in
a draw and now we have the second game
of the blitz and you know who knows how
how that ended so we're just gonna check
it out Magnus with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6
Knight to f3 g6 and now Knight B to d2
so some sort of an uncommon opening we
have d5 and b3 mmm
Magnus trying to completely throw Maxime
out of book Bishop g7 the ship to be to
end now a5 and here at Magnus took a few
seconds to think about the position he
continued with a 4 with castles and here
sorry
and there is one game where nights the
if I was played but here III is a new
move so as of move 7 already we have a
completely new game
Bishop to f7 a nice square for the dark
square bishop with Bishop to e2 Magnus
prepares the castle and Knight to c6 now
Magnus castles and knights the b4 now
putting pressure on the c2 pawn so just
c3 pushing the knight back however not
right away first night the e1 just
guarding the C 2 square and only after
night Stewie for now c3 and getting rid
of the knight pushing it back to e 6c 6
with Knight captures on d2 Queen
captures and the knight back to c6 now
Maxime has ePHI Vince toured with Knight
to d3 and not be v as planned with
Knight captures on e5 Knight captures D
characters and Bishop captures and here
just rook F to D 1 where Coulson says ok
if you you're deep one is under attack
if you defend it I'm just gonna play c4
attack the center your dark square
bishop is also under attack so if you
trade then I have a nice hook on the
same file as your queen
and you're gonna have problems here with
the d5 pawn at some point I might
capture and create an isolated d5 pawn
which I will make a target for the for
the rest of the game so after looking
after the one we have Queen to d6 by
Maxine also and there were some some
other options but this seems to work as
Maxime will show the h2 point is under
attack
so here Carlson could play something
like f4 pushed up the ship back and then
grab the pawn however after Queen to b6
your b3 pawn is under attack your III
pawn is under attack this will come with
the check so black will just be better
here and also after Queen to d6 there
are ideas like c4 which run into simply
trading everything D capture screen
capture C captures we have captures
captures on e5
and now just captures on c4 completely
trading down into into an equal endgame
and of course
Magnus decides not to do any of those
things he decides to go for Bishop to a3
instead so the Queen and rook are under
attack if you want to not lose the
exchange you have to play c5 this is
what Maxine plays there is no time for
Bishop captures because after the King
moves then you'll have to choose do you
want to lose the exchange or you're
you're facing g3 which will trap your
bishop so Queen captures on d5 now that
c5 has been played we have Queen
captures on d5 rook captures and now as
the Bishop to e3 has been played the
secret pawn is no longer defended just
Bishop captures on c3 now attacking the
rook and the now rook to d1 rook the c1
was also possible maybe even better as
after this Bishop before characters and
captures you do have access to c7 square
you could go rook to b5 put pressure on
the b7 pawn maybe put the bishop on f3
seems a like an idea but Magnus went to
rook a to d1 instead and now Bishop to
b4 you defend the pawn here so Bishop
captures C captures and only now Bishop
to c4 putting pressure here on the f7
point and now if you can somehow get
your rooks to the seventh rank it would
be great but it requires a lot of moves
since especially since the bishop
controls the d7 square
but okay Bishop to e6 by Maxine now look
the b5 going after the b7 point and now
rook F to d8 threatening mate in one
so here at Magnus plays rook to d4
now if captures you will be able to
capture back with the pawn and then
start pushing your past pawn onto the d5
and and beyond so ripped eight the c8
and here
Magnus decides to trade on the eight as
if he starts improving the position of
the King he might just lose the game
because rook captures pawn captures and
the rook captures on c4 now if you
capture Bishop captures with check and
you lose the you lose the rook captures
captures and now a for the two connected
passports will win the game easily so
here at Magnus straits rook captures and
e8 rook captures and now Magnus starts
to bringing the King into the game
Bishop captures on c4 now B captures
which creates a very strong past be pawn
for Maxine and the now rook to d2 now
cutting the White King off from the
second ranked rook captures on b7 and
now rook to 80 going after the a4 pawn
we have c5 Magnus starts pushing his
passport rook captures an a4 and now
King to e2 just pushing c6 also playable
but then you get rook to a1 with check
and you get behind the past point in
time so here Magnus starts improving the
position of the King King e2 we looked
at a three cutting off the White King
from the third rank now and now c6 I
will look to c3 putting a room behind
the past pawn as you as you have to do
c7 now the point is nicely defended but
now King to g7 of course not allowing
check and bring you a queen into the
game we rook to e7 now Magnus will have
to trade his past C pawn for the a pawn
we have b3 rook captures an a5 rook
captures on c7 and now rook the b5 here
is the one of those cases where it's
actually better not to put the room
behind the past pawn because here it
loses a valuable valuable temple e for
clearing the e3 square for the King is
the best way to do it but when the time
is low and you're playing blitz
rook the b5 seems like a great idea so
rook the CT with check now if the King
goes to d3 then you start
picking off the Kings iPhone so Magnus
had to go to f3 but now you get b2 and
now you have this monster passport and
the white king is completely cut off
from the second-ranked
so rook to b6 now Magnus will try to
keep the black king away from the pond
but the problem is the black king can
just go all the way here attack the rook
and then after the rook moves start
going all the way down to 2 to the C 1
square and if this happens then
maxime wins the game so let's see what
happens with h5 by maksim first h3 and
now keep the f8 starting to realise the
plan we have g4 by Magnus and now just
h4 of course maxime not interested in
trading he he prefers pawns on the on
both sides of the board g5 now maybe you
will be able to capture this pawn at
some point but very unlikely as then you
will make DF to pawn a target King g7 we
have E for now by Magnus King to d7 King
III and King to c7 now the first plan
first part of the plan is realized rook
has to go back and now king c6 we look
back to b8 king c5 and now that's the
problem you don't gain anything by
winning the rook if ro captures you just
bring the Queen into the game so black
wins this so we have F 4 by Magnus King
to c4 and now f5 we have King to c3 and
now King to f4 he wants to help out with
with the pushing of the pawns but look
to g2 now we have F captures and g 6f
captures and g6 and E 5 now there are a
lot of more precise ways to play the
same game but both of them are extremely
low on time so we have looked eetu now
mvl is ready to realize the idea of King
to c1 and then put the rook in front of
the King to block all checks from the
white rook rook the b6 and now comes
King to see to rook c6 check King to b1
and the now rook to d6 check with King
to c1 rook the c6 check and here we have
rook to c2 now there are no more chicks
and next move maxime is bringing a queen
into the game rook the b6 and now comes
look the c-4 with check and it was in
this position that
scoffs and resigned at the game as there
is nothing more to be done here
the king will move and after the king
moves you will just bring a queen in to
the game
White will give up a rook and even
though you have a past a pawn it's not a
problem because black just brings the
King into the game the white king cannot
cross the fourth-ranked in this
variation and at some point you will
have to play something and now you are
very much in time to get behind the pawn
king before you're gonna go rook e8 King
here characters with check and of course
the rook and King against the King of
course win so now after this rook the
c-4 check Magnus resigned and mvl takes
the first win in this in this match
between Magnus Carlsen and hit and
himself so great game by mvl and really
not another common thing that Magnus
will lose in an endgame but like I
usually say it's just you know anything
can happen so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Prakash Sakura Marius in Sinhala and
[ __ ] [ __ ] for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event as now Magnus has to catch up
and but if he wins at least one with the
game he will he will be able to equalize
so we'll see how it goes
thank you all I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day